some ideas abarth social innovation
applies rural communities and food
systems e loris colby appear to be a
strange combination batte al think this
is the best way to talk about jogging o
di features and bust but i think che se
lo faccio in italiano è meglio perché
perché dovrò toccare dei temi e delle
sfumature che fanno parte di una cultura
mediterranea e anche il linguaggio
vedremo gioca gioca il suo ruolo io
credo che sia d'obbligo per me
raccontarvi cosa ci faccio qui a parlare
di futuro di passato e soprattutto di di
contadini sostanza umani di storie di
agricoltura per me che mi sono formato
in un ambiente legato alla cultura
cyberpunk
non ho nessun altro titolo degno da
poter esibire se non questo mio vissuto
all'interno di questo mondo e se
ricordate uno degli scienziati già dagli
anni sessanta ipotizzavano queste entità
metà uomo metà macchina nate per poter
vivere su altri pianeti dove i confini
tra voi e macchine erano molto sfumati
questo immaginario ha colonizzato tutta
una generazione di filmografie diciamo
di letteratura e fuori da questa
estetica non potevamo immaginarci che
dopo qualche anno
tutti noi siamo dei cyborg perché con
questo in tasca noi abbiamo un
estensione ai nostri sensi completa
determinato il nostro posizione nello
spazio abbiamo l'estensione per lo
stupito la nostra vista possiamo creare
processare contenuti inviarli al pari di
ogni broadcast e la cosa interessante
che oggi con le tecnologie emergenti che
ben conosciamo
tutto questo è mappa bile e questo è un
grafo sociale parla della rete delle mie
relazioni e su primo purtroppo è stato
il mercato a capire questa opportunità è
quindi c'è stata questa corsa ma con
strumentazioni di cui ci occupiamo da
anni quindi a mappare monitorare qualche
modo capitalizzare questa densità di
intelligenza all'interno
dell'info sfera con strumentazioni
adatte e quindi tanto da creare un
filone chiamato addirittura marketing
non convenzionale ma cos'è non
convenzionale realtà la cosa vera non
convenzionale che non erano più i soldi
attori di mercato a ad agire è che tutti
potevamo agire nella società con azioni
che avevano anche di cadute di mercato
tuttavia la cosa non ci suonava complete
abbiamo cominciato a fare una serie di
summer school creando una rete nel mondo
di studiosi più potete vedere personaggi
da bill emmott michel bauwens ad amare
se un john grant e tanti altri per
capire se tutto questo riguardasse non
soltanto il marketing ma anche la
possibilità di un'innovazione sociale e
vedevamo che cela sempre di più in
questa riappropriarsi da parte dei
cittadini della funzione di costruttori
dell'immaginario la necessità di creare
nuove risposte a problemi sociali e
mettendo in atto dei processi di
integrazione che al di là di ogni
ideologia cercavano in strade di
ibridazione tra mercato non mercato e
non profit delle risorse delle risorse
dal basso ai problemi del contemporaneo
è quindi nasce tutto questo approccio
della social innovation oggi sono
quattro anni che ci ha lasciato il
professore fabris a cui in tutti noi
dobbiamo pagare un pegno per le ricerche
fatto in questi anni dove era stato lui
a dare enfasi a questo concetto di suo
siting creato nel 93 tabernacolo a ed
altri che noi abbiamo riattualizzato
questo concetto del del suo siting
societing reloaded proprio come
possibilità di pensare a una nuova etica
del welfare che contemplasse la
possibilità di mettere insieme comunità
idee vincenti e impresa è inutile dire
che due candita adesso di tutto questa
cosa anche in italia ha subito avuto la
sua forza di impatto no pensate a tutto
questo movimento delle startup
sembrerebbe una delle parole più in voga
negli ultimi anni e tuttavia c'è
sembrato che in italia il tutto ha preso
la veste un po di una jack pot economy
non sembra quasi l'etica del colpo gobbo
nel gratta e vinci
ho un'idea brillante invento la sfiga la
venda un venture capital e faccio un
pozzo dei soldi
e gli altri
quindi ecco a una volta diciamo una
risposta dell'ego per carità e che
sicuramente contempla un genio un certo
genio italiano ma non è sicuramente la
risposta sociale no quindi per eventuali
politiche di sviluppo e certamente
quindi il modello forse della silicon
valley non bensì attanagliava quella che
è la situazione italiana non abbiamo
cominciato a capire se ci fosse una via
italiana alla social innovation e
abbiamo mappato che non abbiamo
ricercato abbiamo visto che in realtà in
maniera inconsapevole c'erano tanti
innovatori sociali tantissimi ragazzi
che nel contemplare un loro una loro
idea di business in realtà producevano
benefici anche nella nella comunità
non ci crederete l'abbiamo trovato in
tutta quella mole di ragazzi che
riuscivano a mantenere in piedi questa
tipo al bottom line people planet profit
quindi imprese economicamente
socialmente ambientalmente responsabili
che erano i nuovi contadini 3.0
c'è una generazione di ragazzi con una
coscienza globale skills tecnologici che
hanno viaggiato che usano internet che
per scelta tornano alla terra e non lo
fanno soltanto con la zappa lo fanno col
tablet quindi riportando quindi
innanzitutto la voglia di fare una vita
diversa e quindi mettono nel bagaglio
quindi anche delle economie c'era questo
ragazzo di londra che adesso fa il
contadino del cilento dice alex io la
guadagnavo 12.000 euro al mese per
potermi poi godere quei quindici giorni
di vacanza che era il giorni che sognavo
oggi guadagno 2000 euro al mese e faccio
la vita che mi piace secondo ciclo hanno
guadagnato ci pensa e forse ci ha
guadagnato perché è felice ma al di là
di tutto questo comunque come dire c'era
la possibilità di mettere oggi c'è la
possibilità di mettere in gioco quindi
tutte le competenze quindi tutto quel
bagaglio dell'info sfera e quindi di
cosa succede succede che se vediamo sono
questi gli operatori che dal basso sanno
risemantizzazione
le categorie del contemporaneo
pensiamo al tempo ancora una volta
facciamo un salto nel mediterraneo dalle
nostre parti il tempo una volta aveva
due nomi kronos e carlos il como se il
tempo lineare
c'è il tempo dell'ingaggio e il tempo
inesorabile che vuoi di lui scorre è il
tempo della fabbrica il tempo del
mercato se vogliamo pensate anche in
termini metaforici un po come il
broadcast la televisione in una
televisione a prescindere da noi c'è il
suo palinsesto cioè il telegiornale alle
13 e magari ci aggreghiamo a pranzo per
questo carosello che mi dice quando devo
andare a letto invece c'è un'altra
metafora quella del contemporaneo che
youtube dove io posso scegliere pezzi di
presente e di passato e di futuro posso
vedermi
l'ultimo film all ultima invenzione
tecnologica il documentario è happy days
degli anni 70 quindi c'è questo tempo
che non è più lineare ma è puntiforme
quindi nel kairo's il tempo come scelta
il tempo interno
io il futuro e il presente il passato in
maniera puntiforme e quindi il tempo
diventa una scelta e quindi questi
ragazzi cosa fanno
non si tratta quindi di contemplare una
idea naif di ritorno al passato
prendono elementi del passato e li
mischiano con le potenzialità del
presente per creare delle soluzioni al
loro contemporaneo mese non ci è
sembrata una cosa interessante
intenzione è interessante forse rivedere
anche come questi ragazzi riescono ad
esem anti zara il concetto di spazio
noi abbiamo una comunità abbiamo un
luogo che è matera ma questo è anche un
iper luogo perché la somma anche di
tutte le conversazioni che partono da
matera no quindi trasforma una terra in
una narrativa che parte dal territorio
abbiamo tutte le informazioni con matera
quindi i livelli di realtà aggiunti
aumentati non si parla di società
aumentata quindi o il territorio più
tutte le informazioni e reale
tutte le aggiunte che noi diamo il
territorio e poi o l'informazione su
matera sono materia come narrativa a
prescindere dal luogo fisico cioè
materia è un patrimonio che non ha più
avrà i suoi confini politici in un
perimetro geografico ma la parola matera
la parola basilicata non descrive tutte
le geografie possibili di matera e
certamente non è un patrimonio sud e dei
materani quindi pensiamo anche solo in
termini di immaginario di produzione di
produzione anche simbolica intorno al
luogo
quindi tornando ci era sembrato quindi
questo non siamo stati loro i veri
social network proprio perché come
dicevo riuscivano a portare avanti delle
imprese che erano ambientalmente
sostenibili di per sé vedremo perché
socialmente sostenibili perché
riattivano la comunità
tuttavia spesso questi sogni diventavano
un po carenti sull'aspetto delle
economicamente sostenibile quindi spesso
c'è una molla talmente forte no di
rigetto porte di downshifting rispetto
al al vivere metropolitano a un certo
tipo di vita che era l'entusiasmo che
spingeva a fare delle scelte
tuttavia un entusiasmo che all'interno
della nostra società se non c'è poi dopo
un po la possibilità di pagarci le
bollette si corre rischio che poi si
ritorna a timbrare il cartellino magari
angolo la frustrazione di aver fallito
un sogno e quindi cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo realizzato un aula magna
l'abbiamo riempita di questi social
innovator abbiamo iniziato a fare
prendere i modelli business model cammas
e cioè dobbiamo cominciare a rari
progettarli sulla base delle esigenze no
di questa nuova classe e abbiamo creato
ecco progettato una nuova possibilità di
essere sul mercato che andasse al di là
della catena del valore classica no che
vede un prodotto piccolino schiacciato
che ormai di bassa qualità c'è il
prodotto non è più il quello che viene
barattato per il suo valore è un
escamotage per mettere in gioco altri
sistemi di valorizzazione cioè io c'ho
un prodotto di merda si può dire di un
prodotto diciamo di bassa qualità e come
sfuggire e che poi crea valore prima
sulla base diciamo della logistica non
pensate della grande distribuzione
organizzata quindi lo stoccaggio la
distribuzione di questo prodotto poi c'è
la parte del branding no per inventarsi
tutte queste finte storie per creare
valore se un prodotto cioè le scarpe
reebok c'è da come sono fatte in cina
fanno schifo però comunque il fatto che
va tutta la pubblicità c'era e si è
disposti tutti vanno a pagare 200 euro
perché c'è questo sistema di
valorizzazione per non parlare poi di
quello più cattivo quello che si è
portato un po dove siamo che quello
della finanza il supermercato
mica vende gli yogurt i salatini
eccetera c'è il mercato il supermercato
fa i soldi sul tempo non si se il tempo
è denaro cioè loro barattano il contante
che noi ripartiamo gli portiamo con il
fatto che strozzano nel tempo i
fornitori e quindi li paghino dopo 180
giorni 120 giorni e quindi su quello
scarto finanziario si crea valore allora
ci siamo posti questa possibilità e
sento prodotto lo rimettiamo al centro e
quindi andiamo a valorizzare abbiamo
visto questi ragazzi che venivano da
esperienze disparate chi aveva
recuperato un grano tipico del cilento
altri avevano rimesso in gioco diciamo
la nocciola dop giffonese lavoravano
tutti molto diciamo su questi archivi
della memoria quasi che erano
rappresentati da questo patrimonio della
biodiversità che in italia
diciamo un sentono capitale fortissimo
detto ok
mettiamolo al centro non lo facciamo
diventare più la il gradino più basso
della catena del valore e vediamo un po
branding finanza logistica come possono
di significarsi e rendere sandra perché
abbiamo visto che la logistica diventava
disintermediazione quindi c'è tutto un
movimento
anche soltanto ai mercatini di campagna
amica di coldiretti dove ai gas di cui
si parlava prima denis dove c'è appunto
la disintermediazione tra chi produce e
chi consuma è quindi ancora una volta
vedete in un mercatino rionale troviamo
quei famosi valori di prua station che i
guru del socialisti e marketing di
vendono a caro prezzo
in realtà parliamo di questo di una
relazione disintermediata vedevamo che
il branding quindi la necessità di
inventare finte storie perché è un
appeal su un prodotto di scarsa qualità
era sostituito dallo story telling reale
autentico del territorio tutto il
patrimonio antropologico
la storia di quel prodotto è un
intangibile per il quale se riusciamo a
sistematizzare questi valori in le
persone sono disposti anche a pagare di
più c'è un pubblico mondiale essere
internazionale che è disposto a comprare
e pagare bene dei prodotti di grande
qualità
oggi invece parlano con dei produttori
campani di un olio di grande eccellenza
ci raccontavano questa storia che
avevano venduto per un anno tutta la
produzione alla grande distribuzione
organizzata è in realtà erano stati
pagati pochissimo in tempi lunghissimi
è questo quello che era sembrato un
grande affare in realtà l'aveva
impoveriti tutto questo è qui l'aspetto
più interessante trasforma quella
accumulazione di natura finanziaria nou
dove io accumulo questi capitali che
vanno nelle mani di gruppi che spesso
magari poi li portano fuori ne fanno
altro in un meccanismo continuo di
redistribuzione del valore della
comunità cioè questo azzeramento in
questa disintermediazione questa
valorizzazione anche del patrimonio di
intangibili dello storytelling
territoriale mette continuamente in
gioco redistribuzione del valore e
quindi vediamo che si dà una runa al
social innovation belle sistemi diverso
dove il prodotto al centro e vediamo che
al posto quindi di di logistica branding
e finanza troviamo disintermediazione
storytelling redistribuzione però sempre
dove la comunità la fa da padrone c'è
tutto questo avviene con il con voi
il meglio della comunità che non è più
target non è neanche prosumer è parte
integrante diciamo del processo
tutto questo con una valorizzazione a
tutti i livelli dei valori intangibili e
del patrimonio culturale delle comunità
che dirvi avevamo detto che fatto questo
abbiamo messo su un network di persone e
ho visto un po tutti gli amici
ricercatori che negli anni a vari
livelli da john grant del green
marketing adam arvidsson della social
innovation e tantissimi altri che si
occupavano diciamo di queste tematiche
insieme a dei molti di questi
giovanissimi come vi dicevo avevano una
cultura di natura anche manageriale e
abbiamo realizzato questo rural hub che
vuole essere un hacker space for next
capture quindi un luogo di
sperimentazione per per la nuova
agricoltura quindi un posto che ad oggi
ha una sua sede fisica in questo ex
agriturismo alle porte della costiera
amalfitana e che sta ospitando una serie
di ricercatori internazionale in questa
modalità di coworking
come dire temporaneo e nomadico ma che
in realtà vuole essere soprattutto un
luogo punto d'incontro di ricerca e il
progetto va l'intenzione poi di di
creare una costellazione di luoghi
fisici che poi si ha detto si adattano
anche alle diverse esigenze dei diversi
territori
adesso questo progetto è cofinanziato
dal ministero di università della
ricerca a un tantissimi partner
interessanti internazionali e ci
sforziamo appunto di muoverci in questa
direzione abbiamo una serie di di
attività con arduino stiamo progettando
un quid è una serie di tour di
formazione proprio per arduino per
l'agricoltura presente abbiamo visto in
questa mappatura in un'intersezione
molto forte tra questi non levi colture
l'utilizzo di queste di queste
piattaforme e spesso questi giovani li
vivono come due mondi separati
abbiamo visto che invece mettendoli
insieme si possono creare l'opportunità
fortissime in termini proprio di
progettazione low cost per lo sviluppo
della loro
impresa abbiamo preso tutti i modelli di
business classici quindi business model
cammas e tutto il resto e le abbiamo ri
autorizzati per per questo tipo di scopo
proprio nella convinzione che partendo
quindi dal dall'alimentazione dal
prodotto si riesce a creare una serie di
valorizzazione quindi si può lavorare
sull'impatto ambientale perché un certo
tipo di agricoltura favorisce non solo
la biodiversità ma non desertifica i
terreni i boschi curati non sono
sottoposti a incendi e desertificazione
eccetera
un certo tipo di agricoltura che
favorisce quindi anche il patrimonio
storico e antropologico della nostra
diversità l'alimentazione che ha degli
effetti poi anche sulla salute
e qui inutile dirlo voglio dire che si
parla molto per esempio di celiachia e
per esempio questi cani antichi che
hanno recuperato questi ragazzi nel
cilento hanno un contenuto proteico più
basso e sono fruibili anche da da chi
soffre di questa patologia e per come
abbiamo detto ha un impatto
dal nostro punto di vista virtuoso sulle
politiche diciamo di di sviluppo
economico di certe aree del mediterraneo
e il mediterraneo appunto è un posto qui
questo progetto guarda ma soprattutto
anche del sud d'italia
che dirvi noi siamo work in progress
qui ci sono i contatti dateci una mano
se avete delle idee avete qualche
suggerimento
aspettiamo voi per metterlo in pratica
la prospettiva dal nostro punto di vista
è come come diceva franco cassano che
bisogna riguardare i nostri luoghi
nella duplice accezione di riguardare le
vene riguardo di avere curano del nostro
territorio del nostro patrimonio storico
ma anche di guardarli con un occhio
nuovo e quindi non è detto che anche
l'agricoltura debba essere un ritorno
knife al passato ma c'è la possibilità
quindi di risemantizzazione su un modo
noi le dell'agricoltura concetti proprio
come lo spazio il tempo e comunità
grazie mille